I'm Jeff 1000 IU x'd to be an automotive
assembly device living in central
Northeast Ohio now I'm in LA hanging
with my best friend Summer Glau I feel
like I should lose some weight and color
my hair but I don't have any well I'd
never surfed before so of course I was
nervous but as soon as I got out there
the fear just melted away face washed
over me oh that's beautiful it was until
I almost died well you like you should
words what do you want you wanna walk oh
no no no no no no no nose sorry you're
on vacation yeah I was on vacation but I
I almost died I was focused on my
balance I see this this dark spot in the
water and it was a sharp no what you're
watching Somers telling daddy a very
interesting story sorry she gets it
yeah so what happened well I'll tell you
hey baby
that's what I do not want daddy to get
it too
oh I can't be mean to you I love you too
but you on the back bath with Daddy we
complete fluffy bubby don't play dress
up you want to dress up as an air
hostess
can I wear you is it hot let me wear
using